[Music]
[Music]
strangers
[Music]
hi i'm nick the uh depaul ah sorry
you're austin right yes
hi nice to meet you
i didn't recognize you man
yeah stephen just told me to come in
like this because i was ready just like
this anyway so
yeah i looked up and i go oh that's the
right car but it's a broad driver
hi this is my wife
[Music]
all right welcome to ash wednesday today
is a i guess a comedy round table
um of course you know dave landau and uh
hello oh boy
one of the funniest men alive and i've
talked about this quite a bit and i
don't think he's upset when i said put
him in the company of like nor mcdonald
because that's
that's a compliment but uh nick depaolo
is here and your people can go listen to
your podcast uncensored is it the comics
gym
the comics gym.com or nickdip.com but
the comics gym is the permanent home
that i've been chased to
right and that's you know i before the
sh before we started
recording i said comics jim and then you
said no it's the comics gym
isn't that a bit presumptuous um all
i know is you got to be very precise
steven when you're giving out these
addresses
right and i'm saying because uh i was
trying to get on
uh what was it young latino housewives
sure
and uh i kept using.org apparently
that's not right i don't think it works
because you're less surly
this is the first you've you know you've
noticed this you've met nick before yes
you
you seem like you've even though you're
angrier about the state of the country
yeah
you're less irritable in person well i
first met nick before he moved to
georgia
okay that'll tell you right now that's
what happened yes is that what happened
he's right actually
yeah because i've heard that since i
moved to george by more than
two people yeah definitely everybody but
my wife she still thinks i'm a dick
but um yes i think maybe the southern uh
it's taking the edge off even though we
had a mass shooting but you know that
was only two miles from my house
well you know what well and when you're
from new york exactly really it's like
it's like going to sleep to white noise
yeah right you sort of have to seek out
a shooting yes at that point
but yeah that's i've heard that a few
times thank god we pre-taped um
there's also plenty of white noises in
new york
yeah exactly i've seen what happened
with tompkins square park now no no i
mean all the parks in new york it's just
well they're all
never going no i think you mean
washington square park oh that's right
thompson square park was already
horrible that's right alphabets
washington square park i walk through
that every night for 20 years i go to
the comedy cellar
and those arches and stuff and now you
see that's the first thing i'd say when
i get on stage at the seller
i go i'm in a good mood till i get down
here and you're stuck in 1968
playing your guitars in a circle like
waiting for manson and linda kasabian to
show up
i guess someone finally heard you four
45 guys on skateboards with book bags
come on how to open with that
yeah but your freshman nyu at the table
front tablets looking at me
going outside and unlocking their segway
it's all
pissed but the city still bans bird
scooters for some reason oh
while it lives in harlem and then
believe it or not it turned out to be
bad
yeah we know you knew
were you in morningside heights were in
spanish harlem i was in uh 135th
and broadway so i was in uh anyway it's
plenty it was playing it's enough for
you people were getting stabbed in the
park like 10 feet from where i lived and
i was like
and you know what let's just you know
it's our generation they grew up and
they felt slighted over a game of pog
that's all it came down to no but it is
it is a lack of accountability right now
you've created criminal underclass who
feel like they can do whatever they want
we just talked about this the northeast
you know the midwest people would say oh
the midwest the backbone of the country
that's not true anymore
it really it almost feels like it's a
totally different country i mean
michigan we have the worst governor in
the union
and then you're but you're from
massachusetts how does that were you
always
i was right wing was it not because you
were ornery
yeah i get why you associate or the
right wing all the time generally
speaking
maybe you got a good point yeah uh no i
was just
uh common sense i guess that's
considered right wing i guess like my
parents aren't really political at all
you know my you know my dad might drop
the n-bomb watching the celtics but that
was no i'm kidding he never never in his
life
i'm kidding he called it that ballet
these ash trays by the way what are we
in rome here i know it's so nice i'm
trying to figure viewer
puketron but um boston was so
um so left-wing it it came full circle
oh you know i mean in the 70s you'd
always see a picture about i was you
know a kid from southie throwing a rock
at a bus
and and right you know well it was kind
of democratic there wasn't it but yeah
it's always been because of the kennedys
yeah no they ruined it that's kind of
how michigan was too detroit
but i would almost say that that old
democratic attitude is conservative now
i wouldn't even
i would certainly say this when you get
rid of i mean there's a reason that like
for example you're talking about what's
going on in harlem
um over i think it was 86 right of black
americans either won at least as much of
a police presence as there is now
or more of course right and in detroit
there's i mean it's never been more
clear than that like
um they they understand the necessity
but right the guy might run against
whitmer
black police chief who was sort of never
even mentioned he was a republican if
the election were held today
he would win and i think that the black
democrats they're now the moderate wing
of the party well gil hill was the first
like even known uh you know police chief
in detroit he was in
uh hill cop yeah he was the you know the
guy who swears at axel the whole time
crazy that was the
real police chief of detroit yeah so
they were like oh we were going to get
an actor but this guy's a way bigger
piece of [ __ ]
it was amazing kind of like frank rizzo
from philly yeah
exactly effectively but the difference
was detroit you know you spend a lot of
time in new york or boston is uh if you
want to hide a body in detroit you put
it in grand central state yeah
or if it's that's the place no one
checks remember they would have to there
were a few years at grand central
station
grand central station they were just
clearing out homeless bodies from the
elevator shaft it was just almost dead
oh both
that almost be right above jordan's
steakhouse
boy what's that uh what are those rib
eyes yeah and there you always have to
hear some hipster in a skateboard so
it's coming back it's gotta be that
cream broccoli
some homeless guy's carcass the elephant
man
rotting on floor sits
yeah somebody shot the door to the man's
room i felt a lot of guns
enjoying an 85 steak surrounded by dead
bodies
oh that that must be the turf it's the
midwest yeah it probably had to be
shipped in
now isn't it crazy to think that there
are comedians out there who would want
to cancel the conversation
and i had to use the word cancel but
deem it offensive you know we're just
talking about this before and i make
sure i cleared with you guys
you know john here let me read some
quotes i'll just pull this up so there's
a little bit of research
and against the comics jim.com right is
you the comics gym.com
comics gym the great i am of comedy okay
someone argue uh you know for her jenny
but it's nick
so john oliver says uh you may be
expecting me to say that all public
shaming is bad but i don't actually
think that when it's directed a lot of
good can come of it if someone's caught
doing something racist
it can increase accountability you have
stephen colbert encouraging it bill
maher kind of walking it back
cat williams i don't know what people
got canceled that we wish we had back
who are they anyway but it's going to
get you this always surprises me because
i've talked about this you know from
canada
you have pastors right now who are
jailed in canada for having outdoor
services i've been raiding that
yeah and regardless of whether you're a
christian whether you're a person of
faith or not in the united states
people don't really have a lot of people
i don't feel like happier these
pastors and priests in jail are they
happier in jail yeah they feel like they
have a kinship with john the baptist
until someone brings out a platter they
get nervous you know what i'm saying um
but people always feel like it's never
affected me until you need that right
right kat williams hasn't had that but
once once they come for him you see it
with kevin hart right once it comes for
them then it's like oh but i
i can't be canceled like in canada i had
people would say i don't feel my freedom
of speech is infringed
until you want to go to church they will
never come after cat williams no
and the only reason kevin hart got a
little bit was because the oscars were
involved
and he's at this level of fame and
did it really hurt his career did he get
cancelled same with
i always bring this example up this is
my litmus test uh which is tracy morgan
oh yeah remember when his wife was
pregnant he said if the baby's
right that's a direct quote yeah oh boy
did that ruin his career i'd say about
six months later he had a series on tbs
right guys so uh that you know you know
i mean they yeah
how do you cancel kat williams you take
away one of his 40 million dollar
specials on netflix
obviously yeah you know it's a whole
different barometer of
well he also adopted a lot of kids and i
love kevin he's really funny yeah cat
williams yeah he adopted a lot of kids
like he's a decent but he also yeah he
got beaten up by a kid i was going to
say if they don't need to cancel they'll
just send out a fleet of 15 year olds
yeah
but even like seven years ago that kid
got them all [ __ ] fish board
well i that by the way i think you're
cigar yeah give me that place thank you
so much there you go
thank you sir um but he's i didn't know
that he slept a guy in a target he did
he slaps a guy right
in a target you know who has yeah i mean
who hasn't won
yeah don't be shy enough that thing went
completely out you have to tap the ash
and then
oh and by the way for people who want to
know uh no endorsement no sponsor but i
am smoking remote allowing us again by
aj fernandez
i've talked about a poor guy he went
from cuba to uh no he went from uh
uh where did he go from lebanon to cuba
then the cuban stuff happened then he
went from cuba to nicaragua the poor son
of a [ __ ]
the guy literally just went to the worst
places what are you talking about the
guy who makes these cigarettes
um so cat williams in a target yeah well
and also
if you pull out any cat williams special
you can cancel them for
literally every joke right right yeah so
i just kevin hart has always been not
that he's not funny but he's
danced that line of like i'm just middle
of the road enough
to where he gets tons of movies he's
safe he's safe
yeah cat williams never was i i guess
yeah i i guess i can see that but uh it
still is remarkable to me that anyone in
this realm of comedy is
unaware of how important it is to be
able to you know you kind of talk about
how they won't cancel someone like kevin
hart has this
great career but what i think a lot of
people miss and um this actually had
this conversation with dennis miller
like years ago he was like as long as
you're funny i said but the problem is
if you never get to build the audience
through being funny because you get
cancelled through people on the way up
when people use the term canceled
culture i
i hate it there's a difference between
with stand-up you know if you're funny
or not
the issue with cancelled culture is a
few angry people like we just saw with
charles barkley
who then get those in charge of all
information at
social media companies at uh you know
multi-conglomerate uh
cable news corporations to then ban you
it's not that people are offended
but a few people have a disproportionate
amount of power
and it's the same with bookers and clubs
and so it's like well yeah but no one
might ever know if this guy is fine it's
kind of like i always wondered with
the best athlete did they blow out their
knee in college right because they train
them too hard but i don't
i don't agree with that statement as
long as you're funny
these discussions i'll be watching even
tucker has like adam carol who i like
again i like adam yeah
i mean he's supposed to be the bad boy
and and billy burr who i love by the way
right but they get labeled these these
are the new bad boys pushing against the
friggin you know i was saying this [ __ ]
on tough crowd in 2000
yeah and you sort of it did like you
said
it was a both a bittersweet yeah it sort
of got me
known right but it also i don't know how
many you know
how many um clubs or whatever
theaters you know even now i get my
my managers said they went to you they
saw you say on your show
i said uh after i see it all that
rioting in the summertime yeah i said
well you know we need another
kent state
you know and uh they saw that one line i
was on the books at this theater down
south for
six months and they called that that's
the question bill burr and i think you
know you're both
obviously guys from boston i love billy
eddie's hilarious and i think you know
you would be
you would both fit under there kind of
same generation coming up yeah straight
white male
pretty rough and i will say billy you
know softened it a little bit and i
think you put your your foot on the gas
the whole way through yes
and he was another one who came out
recently and said like you know [ __ ]
can't
cancel culture i mean what you know like
it's a couple of people just wait two
days
then it stops like that's not what
happens that's not you become [ __ ]
the rich little of us
you know it's true
when i got bumped by sean hannity's
freedom tour for rich little
did you really oh god
they asked me if i did a good rank they
asked me if i did a good reagan
i got to say no that's the saddest thing
that's ever happened to you
horrible i have to i have to hear rich
little go out to another rascal flat
song like hey have you heard reagan
mafias
bad news bob nelson's dusting off his
football helmets
i don't know like was french travelina
not available
just please sorry we got gallagher
someone resurrected the corpse of uh
milton berlin can i tell you the best
fred
travelina joke ever is it his joker joe
no
it's it's richard lewis's joke it's me
and artie's maybe our favorite bit of
all time
he was talking about when you're
watching boxing and there was a couple
of real controversial fights with the
ref jumped in too quickly
you know and he goes he goes now
sometimes they jump in too quickly
and then they'll go over to the guy
sitting in the corner and then the ref
goes to the guy
who's praised travelina
fights
is
when he got in the view it was my
favorite by the way it was the same
episode
he got cancelled uh back then and i mean
actually abandoned from the view
because he said uh george bush had just
become president
yeah it's good to get a good guy in the
house and get murderers out of the
white house you know and then what
murder he goes hey bill clinton didn't
you know
he killed a guy and they banned him for
life but in that same show he talked
about
going to the friars club that's my
favorite you talked about going to the
friars club and this was on i remember
watching with my dad i just i loved noor
mcdonald
as a kid and i'm watching with my dad
and i remember sitting there crying
he says you know i go to the i don't
know if it was a friar's club it was
something like that where i get invited
to this
you know club you know and uh they uh
they tell me you know oh you're gonna go
there and hang on it's kind of you know
oh you know barbara it's a roast right
and uh
but then i realized when i get there
it's all these old communities but not
that good comedian not like bob hope for
milton berlin you know like uh
like uh frank travolina and then i
realized i said like hey this guy over
here uh
you know somebody asked me if i want
whiskey or something and he goes he
can't have any
you know and i realize that every joke
is uh about me being a homosexual man
and i'm not a homosexual man as you well
know says meredith vieira
right away she's stunned he goes but i
realize that's how they you know this
old timer was a southern unit so i uh
i was turned over to uh uh i think it
was frank traveling because i turned
into frank and i said uh
you know uh he likes uh having sex with
guys you know
and it was a he looked at me like this
you know that was all he does she goes
and it was you could hear a pin drop
then
he's just he has no idea where he's
going so great he's making it up
yep he just knows and you know he has
that confidence when you corner yourself
the
i'm going to pull out a funny oh yeah
that's the beauty
it's the best i love that free
association well yeah and the
the weekend updates that he did where
it's like look don't make fun of michael
jackson don't make fun of o.j so he does
it that day he's like uh
at least repressive michael jackson are
getting divorced uh lisa me presley
wishes he was more of a homebody
and michael jackson wishes she was more
of a seven-year-old boy
and the whole place is like groaning
like when you i was laughing so hard i
never listened to the audience you watch
it now
they're like pissed and he goes oh you
haven't heard he's uh he's a
pedophile
really that's our job yeah sorry
to say what you guys are thinking yeah i
uh
it was actually almost to me a moment of
i think i've told the story uh
i was a fox news for four and a half
years and i never met roger ailes
i only knew they said like uh the lady
who runs it now susan scott i've never
had anything but a good interaction with
her she said
rodriguez doesn't think you're funny and
i thought oh and then i found out he
banned noor mcdonald when he would fill
in from there there you go
it's a compliment i felt like it was a
column now it doesn't mean of course
that i'm necessarily funny
but i just took it as okay it doesn't
mean that i'm not funny because you know
roger ailes
i think it had something to do with the
fact that i did a sketch on my on my
show about him uh motorboating megan
kelly in the green room before it came
out
before this news yeah that might have
stuck in his craw yeah they might have
been upset because it was so accurate
yeah
yeah it was well known i remember people
saying like why don't you just focus
because i was i was there it wasn't
this was pre me too yeah this happened
at fox tape's not pulling your hairs in
there
there's no mic back little handsy um
it's funny because that's not that far
off like little handsy i
the last time i was at the addison
improv it was bruce bruce
and his opener black boy two eyes and me
talk about uncomfortable and that was my
prize how did you get hooked into that
one
so here's what happened there was what
before myspace comedy existed
on there which is how i got like doing
the just for laughs it was like kind of
at the same time like ding
ding cook was doing it a little actually
a little before him but obviously you're
like nine didn't get as big
yeah i was i was 17 17 yeah and uh
there was a so you think you're funny
contest in myspace where like people
submitted stand-up videos
and i won and the prize was to go open
at a
in uh i want to say i want to say it was
in tampa florida for bruce bruce but pay
my own way
i was like well i can't do that so then
they said all right well maybe if you
happen to be in the same
area of the road and you know my family
at that point wasn't too far from
madison improv so
that was my prize i bid out like twelve
thousand people
to open up for black boy and uh i don't
i didn't know this like when he would
you know bruce bruce yeah 400 pounds he
comes out it seems like a fighter i
didn't realize the bruce bruce everybody
and that means the music starts the
downbeat and he comes out with his
entourage
and he's walking out it was like a
two-minute walkout
and i just didn't know how to you know
these were cultural differences so like
pinstripes and all that
yeah i mean i wouldn't i mean at that
point it's not really pin stripe
they're going every which way he crushes
yeah oh yeah oh yeah
i mean there's something that you can
only do when you're a 400 pound black
guy
yeah that is just history in this suit
[Laughter]
well it's funny you said though about
tough crowd i mean that was patrice
and the fact that youtube played so well
if he that's why i watched that show
honestly
you and patrice on that show made that
show that's what was always
we did stir the drink a bit you did as
we
what was the the one of the funniest
things everyone was going to tell you
i'm going to ruin it but it was when
he's going to tell everybody had
diabetes
because i got one of those two things to
kill black men that wasn't on tough
crowd though oh it wasn't no that was
i i vh1 gave me a show
oh is that a pilot yeah okay yeah what
do you mean really what kind of [ __ ]
kind of comments that
uh because you're taking each one you'd
be an [ __ ]
so patrice was my first guest because he
shows up
about 25 minutes late or whatever and i
go where where he goes i had a physical
man i go so yeah everything check out
he goes i got nick i got nine of the 10
things that killed
i goes one of them handguns
the funniest he laughed as hard as i've
ever seen him laugh
you know and and and that's called see
i i don't sound as connie they always
say music that's the way we can all get
along but no it's comedy
yes that that cuts through more horse
you know him laughing at that
and and you know i mean it was so
perfect
because he was being vulnerable which
you never saw patrice be
yeah and then you just got it like it
was so
that's why we made it so good he was
trying to have this moment and it was
just an immediate joke yeah just
completely just cut right to the bottom
and then everybody would jump in even
you know dorado said some
stuff to patrice it was way worse than i
think i said i love it
but i get admiring that joke there's no
fat on that bone yeah
that is as good as it yeah as a joke can
get it right one of them handguns
i'll never do anything in my life better
than that it was funny though
and then i guess that didn't get picked
up yeah you know i had
and another it was part of the uh was
that part of the same no this is another
deal i had
um with border something productions and
we
i had breakfast with al sharpton up at
rue fans uh
a famous place in harlem breakfast
please was he on prompter
no no we picked him up we picked him up
in a van
comedy central was he miguel sharpton at
the time was he or was it no
he had lost the weight he wasn't as
skinny as now right but you know in
transition
yeah you know he's pretty he was pretty
skinny actually uh but we picked them up
like
on a corner on on whatever uh yeah i
thought it was so sharp
yeah we picked up two wrong guys a guy
who wrote him a [ __ ] in our chapter oh
it's another slam poem yeah yeah
that's the last time i make that mistake
he's got hair straightener yeah
so we had breakfast his place called
ruth anne's or something it's a famous
up in harlem you know and uh it was so
it was great it was just all the menu or
you know
everything was named after you know
malcolm x pancakes yeah
uh you know and uh
i know the place too the chicken and
waffles are amazing and i'm trying to
think of it yeah i'm in there
it's called ruth's root vans i think
it's ruth's uh but
yeah yeah and but it was so great it was
just
you had a good time oh yeah i mean very
charming i feel like saying why do you
waste your brains on the horse
you did you know which just you know but
he's thinking the same thing he's like
where'd you where'd you learn your
politics you know and i go i grew up in
boston he's like oh
[ __ ] i didn't realize you're so liberal
i'm like
i wonder why they you know watching the
nba or whatever
uh but all that i'm making fun of all
the names you know i can't remember some
of the [ __ ]
shopkins like oh jesus he wasn't
offended
no he was like most these people aren't
of course not
you know it's and that is why
today is so horrible i mean uh to so
that's the one way the one thing we do
all have in common you know and
uh to take that away um and like you
said it's just a minority a small group
on on on social media who wield this
power
and and these spineless white executives
at these corporations
most white you know yeah i have a
coca-cola
guilt yeah i have a theorem comedy
nowadays and this relates to what i talk
about quite a bit that that fake victim
uh culture creates real victims now
think of if you're gonna name
at least you would you could argue right
it's always subjective the best comics
of all time
you certainly would put on that list
richard pryor
eddie murphy dave chappelle a lot of
people put chris rock but the point is
12 to 13 of the population they
for a long time made up a
disproportionate amount of great right
now to understand that's not
that makes total sense when you consider
the fact like go to a black church it's
interact it's a part of the culture
right interacting with people razzing
each other
but now in a culture of we need x amount
of female comedians
there you go have you noticed something
there you go there aren't many new
priors
there hasn't really been one since
chappelle nope
well and i've seen but they're going to
get fewer spots because when it used to
do an open mic
right even even when i was and i you
know i'm younger i started in the early
2000s
you would have probably 25 to 30 percent
of the comics would be black and they
were generally very good
because this was you know their open mic
their work their comedy gym
was their family they're these big
households right it's not a part of
necessarily sort of the female
interactive experience but now we say
well we need 50 of women so they have to
be 50
of open mics yeah but only 20 of the
applicants were women
and i just think that now you create
real victims where you have fewer
because who's the minority of the day
well it should be based on victimhood i
mean there should be some sense of
vulnerability and comedy obviously
but part of it i've been pulled up for
years yeah good for you
still haven't found it yeah i'm not
kidding you now every
single issue is so every note my first
20 years then they gave up on me
even like girls like dated but like you
know you could be a little more
vulnerable up there
well every now and then you would do it
you would do it in your way though where
you'd have like the
doctor doing shadow puppets in your ass
yeah what was that that was your half
hour i still remember
wait which one was that oh yeah the
prostate yeah the prostate exactly yeah
yeah yeah i have the best prostate i
know we've all done prostate bits but
yeah colin says i have the best line
i go this guy uh this guy was uh
digging around on my ass with this like
a homeless guy trying to get a quarter
out of a pay phone
call and said that nobody should do any
more prostate jokes after that yeah it
was perfect
and it's like yeah yeah she starts doing
shadow puppets in my head
there's a towel at me like i'm a three
dollar [ __ ] yeah yeah when you're done
you're all covered in low but just
throws a towel like you're five dollars
i'm curious
what your what your coping material is
like and and oh i get great coverage
because i remember
your i remember your bit that had me on
the floor howling about the zika virus
do you remember what that was you said
uh okay i'm sorry i'm gonna i'm gonna
butcher it but then you'll remember
it'll be a queue and then
i don't count on me remembering but uh
well you said uh uh what was this zika
virus said okay do i have this about
right
uh a woman gets the zika virus oh yeah
there's a 50 50 shot the kid's born with
a [ __ ] eminem heb
is that eminem considering that i hear
about the unfathomable pain that is
childbirth
yes you see where i'm going with this
folks
and then you can just hear women in the
crowd going
i forgot all about that i could be
bringing that into my mind
yeah this is the problem when you're 59
fellas trust me
i can't when when you were young and you
did an hour
um and then you'd have to start a new
hour right away but obviously you can't
go out on stage when you're on the road
right and right you know wing an hour so
you you go back to your last album grab
some bit right
but with each year i can't even remember
anything on the last out you know i mean
it forces you to
you're constantly right that's me i
don't know i mean you know i had a few
concussions when i was young but
it's it it makes me perfect i don't know
how that what did you get
were people targeting you with the but
you played baseball play football i
thought you played baseball oh you
played football
yeah that was back in the air i played
511 italian
could be considered intense well again
uh
average about 270 up at maine and uh you
could still get your neck broken let's
put it there
i can imagine yeah yeah it was you know
it wasn't notre dame but
you know you weren't rudy still a lot of
white people
thank you a lot of white kids playing on
the field oh yeah i mean
what what's steve when so it's so funny
because i put on maine like last year
you know and i didn't see one white guy
on the team
we had we had two and of course
i was playing behind this kid lorenzo i
called him a kid lorenzo bullier about
61
215 negative body fat um from he was a
street gang leader in heart fit when he
was growing up
wow still his names are on the all the
new england rushing records
really yeah uh just and a nice guy just
a nice quiet
i was behind him and he he broke his leg
so i had to actually you know on
homecoming to get umass that was my
first big
but he couldn't have been nicer you know
what i mean but i saw some kid give him
they were playing hoops before before
football practice
yeah and this this kid on our team was a
little punk running back yeah
white kid from massachusetts big yap he
pushes lorenzo
goes bang kid went out cold out like a
lot i thought he broke his neck when he
hit the you know just one shot
good lord and loretta just like stepped
over him and
gets the ball yeah you know i mean just
a badass the ref doesn't even say
anything he's like
no there was no reps yeah is that where
your bit comes from about about how at
least in baseball they're honest about
steroids as opposed to like college ball
football yeah
but you must did you see that when
you're oh god yeah up there
they would be sticking each other right
like in the ass cheek in the shower and
i could yeah well so the guy who's in
here on the show that's gerald
morgan he uh he you might need a lighter
there yeah here you go
we need this um he played at notre dame
he was actually so good that kids
here in high school who never would have
been looked at by scouts got to go to
division one schools because everyone
wanted them
and uh he believed that everyone was
nancy
everybody was what everybody was natural
because he was like the only one he was
just naturally he got in the gym am i
doing it right
squat 550 yeah a few of those guys well
you know it was one of those guys bavaro
i
played with him in high school okay he
went to notre dame too
same thing though he he was just he had
the physique of a freak
yeah some guys do but up at maine these
guys these kids from maine
oh my god i'd go really you're gonna
blow out your kidneys for maine football
so let me what look just we should we'll
probably bring one up i don't think
like we'll bring one up here a picture
of you patricia used to joke about this
you were a very good looking
yeah we talked about it earlier yeah you
were an athlete
where did the anger become well no i'm
saying well you are but you know
you used to like girls yeah you were a
good cook and you used to dress well
what's your problem let's talk about
your childhood
but you wait where did this come where
did you say you want to go into comedy
usually it's not the guy
who's you know playing high-end sports
who looks like elvis i was at high-end
but
um i'm from maine i'll tell you what for
a bunch of white kids i'll tell you
well i wanted to go into it before
college
we massachusetts kids just i don't know
there's something in the water up there
my best friend was a kid named bob
murphy it's bodies from uh bulger and he
was funny a little bit
in his own way um yeah bob this kid bob
murphy was my best friend
graduated first or second in our class
actually worked at the think tank for a
while
that guy could have been let him in
before letterman really he used to make
me laugh
till like goddamn cried really he was
just so quick and so smart
and we were in to stand up and he's the
one who said to me
i think i was home from college a hot
summer night he goes let's go into
boston steve sweeney was kind of big on
the radio
doing mayor kevin white so he goes let's
go into one of those clubs we'd never
been a comedy club so we go into
stitches
it's sweeney meanie night kevin meaney
and steve sweeney had a show on
wednesday nights
okay and we went in there and my life
was never the same after
i walked out of there you know i'm still
in college at that point right going oh
my god
i think i want to do this that was like
the heyday of boston oh my goodness
yeah like yeah absolutely when i got out
of college you know
i had my roommate this kid who i met up
at umaine he became an eye doctor in
boston we're living together
and he we almost got into a fight
because he said he thought i was the
funniest guy on the planet and he would
challenge me
to go to an open mic at stitches and i
would never do it
you know you only call me a [ __ ] one i
started to get pissed about it and then
i go you know what he's right
so he like but bob murphy and this other
guy greg zuck who stays at my house
every week and now in savannah he he was
the miami cop
okay okay he he he's four years old he
went to high school my sister but he
would come to our house on sundays and
make me laugh till i thought my ribs are
gonna break
and those two guys i put them in the
credits of my first special
but everybody in boston even kids that
that i hung out with on a periphery were
wise asses and
there's something you know how they're
kind of snobbish up there punky until
you get to know them then they then you
like them
yeah there's something about that up
there but uh bob murphy
he would just do you think there could
ever be those meanie comedy nights today
do you think those are going on to that
degree anymore like do you think that a
young nick would walk into
a comedy club today and see what you saw
that enthralled you i don't know that
it's possible well the last
six months i don't mean like when he was
out and i don't mean that as an insult
but it's like everything that seems to
be a comedy tonight is based on some
sort of yeah it was kevin
and steve sweeney yeah and um yeah many
was just silly funny
i love pepto but hilarious but but but
yeah steve but sweeney
sweeney was rough yeah he was right i
mean i'm sweet i thought i thought it
was a play on words meanie sweeney
because
yeah no i know that's why i clicked you
think that would happen like a like a
night where you go in and
not now no no that's what i'm saying
we're regressing
because i remember that for me now
what's funny is i i wasn't i did acting
before i ever did stand up
and um i saw something but today when
you hurt your knees yeah that was rough
no but uh i missed a lot of school like
i'd be treated on set and then the union
destroyed uh
the energy the film industry in montreal
you know because you could film you can
make it look like old london you can
make it look like france you can make
like new york everything was going there
then the taxes got too too expensive
so i started doing um stand-up but i
grew up always like
letterman was the guy i watched and
that's that was sort of my dream i just
said like oh that's
that's something where i used to watch
him and jay leno i remember telling my
dad saying
jay leno has to uh
he has to write something he has to say
something funny letterman is funny
yeah i didn't know how to describe it um
but even looking back at all of the just
sort of the insubordination from david
letterman he was always poking his
finger in the chest of the authorities
oh yeah
and that's what i grew up loving yeah i
mean even just him in the the ear piece
of rupert or what
do you remember when the show was on in
the mornings are you that big a fan you
know what's funny yeah he actually said
we did an hour and a half show in the
morning yeah no one could do it it was
suicide and i'm thinking that's exactly
what we do
and comparable numbers to what he had in
the morning and we're thinking like
that's why i'm dying
but yeah no it it just you could just
see was like a comedy workshop
i but then i remember watching his later
years going
i would never tune into this right and
what i'm watching the authority figure
telling everyone else what they can and
say and i just thought it would have
been a totally different upbringing
jay those appearances that i still watch
him
when i have nothing else to watch on tv
i go to youtube at two in the morning i
put
jay just put talking jay leno on david
letterman in the 1980s
and 18 appearances will come up right
i've watched them all 10 times
those are what made me finally go to the
open mic
really jay's appearances yeah i couldn't
believe how god
funny he was and after a second one when
when he would come on let him and the
crowd would just like stand
up yeah he he was that impact and he
wouldn't even let dave get a word out
dave goes like we got to go to break he
go oh for crying and yeah
and and instead of interrupting him
during a bit and jake goes she's going
to keep the speed going right
yeah dave's like rolling his eyes
it's fun to watch yeah but dave was i
mean so generous putting him on like
twice a month
yeah and he was everywhere he'd plug
gigs at you and i doing that he's like
he goes like i'm at governors and then
uh and he drive around his motorcycle
all over the country
yeah and he was the guy yeah and he was
a he was a better stand-up than dave
dave was a better host yeah yeah that's
all i know yeah it's two different
you know a perfect example of that sorry
i'm gonna cut you off oh no i just say i
started him once at the comedy magic
club and i always i always liked jalan
for what he was i wasn't
crazy about him like i was letterman
right but when i saw him at comedy magic
club i was honestly blown away oh yeah
yeah you know what
he was but he was so to the letter he
would take a sip of his drink at the
exact same time in everything i can see
that well i
see not i don't know if i agree with
that i saw him at nick's comedy club but
i watched him do two sets
okay two hour sets no no but i'm saying
it was it was good but i watched him do
that actually what uh what's the other
club in long island if it's not
governors wasn't there another one
um uncle vinnie's no that's poor no
there was
there was another one um uh like east
side comedy club i think it was probably
was that maybe it was governors because
i did governor's one and i
remember seeing those two come in too i
saw jay do two sets in a very short
period of time he was probably hurting
the sip at the same time just because
the laugh was so big yeah ashmore thing
like this is a guy who really
fine-tunes it whereas then you have some
people who are just a little bit you
know looser with it yeah and letterman
is just
he he lends himself all the hosting a
good example of that is the last time
conan was on cold bear um conan has
never i mean conan i think it's some
open mics
but conan conan was doing was doing
circles around colbert
it was just it wasn't even close it was
one of those things where like you're
talking about letterman
leno when you watch this you can see
equals and leno is in his element and
letterman is giving him the floor
yeah but it was conan on with colbert
and i don't remember exactly what it was
this was i think when he was launching
like his he changed the format of his
show
oh when he was going into letterman's
seat no no no when when conan was
switching to like his new format
oh gotcha so he was on colbert and it
was just it was all it was almost
you're like it would have been better
for colbert had this contrast never
happened
you know what i mean it's almost like an
opener who is getting up like on a
showcase well i felt
that way about conan when when he's had
comics on even norm one time
he kept interrupt he's like how long has
this bit and he doesn't know that norm
sets these things up and
then reels you in you know when he had
the the beverly hills and i don't
know he's like you left to do a movie
with carrot top because
it should be called box office poison
yeah that was one
yeah colin kept interrupting him and i'm
sitting home going will you let him it's
obviously a [ __ ] you know i mean
but that conan was always nice to me
he's funny in his own way
he's not standing i think he's hilarious
i think he didn't know i think he's okay
he's a clever he's a clever guy
the best host if the guest isn't funny
and you need the host to save it
yeah in other words like letterman likes
to let you sort of squirm and like you
better bring it or i'm going to
let you fail on your own or with joaquin
where it's like well i'm just going to
bury you yes when i try to come in here
and embarrass you yeah but conan is if
the guest isn't great you want that host
to be conan where's like if you watch
kimmel
with a bad guest it's just death yeah
it's just uncomfortable to watch
you have to like watch it through your
you're going to die by embarrassment
changed i mean that's what everybody
loved about him at least we did like
even his first
i was in college when his first show
aired and it was like this is awesome
it's snoop dogg everybody's drunk
it was ridiculous oh yeah but it was so
much fun but over time and then he saw
colbert getting
numbers yep i thought he's the first one
to take the bait i thought
kimmel i mean 100 i'm not a guy who who
says that a
a man can never cry but when he went on
television and cried over cecil the lion
and i pulled up the stats remember my
show that day i was like you realize
that 150 people have been attacked by
lions and just that municipality
like if you have four shark attacks ever
that's the biggest here
it's like ghosts in the darkness every
week and he
was like i can't believe he's a big game
hunter's like that's their economy he
just had
and he was sitting there crying i just i
said there are certain things he can't
unsee
yeah i just couldn't watch him again
yeah yeah i i
i don't know just watch i i get crying
over your kid which he did on the one
episode
gave him crap i'm like i understand that
but ev everything else it's like just
how about your kid being eaten by a
lioness yeah yeah that's right
well you gotta go i wasn't gonna bite
him done
that's like that no wait you were you
weren't always by rich little
i know you are so on the money traveling
out life is a family that's what it was
the frank
the uh the uh sean hannity freedom tours
like him rascal flats and and they're
like
it was rich little what i love about uh
what i loved about new york
conan though was you were on like he put
on comics
yeah they were great yeah he did yes and
i mean that obviously changed in shift
bookers
but i mean when it was the new york
comics going on that is
the best that late nights yeah you gotta
tell doing late night sets
i watched it come on i'm like oh my god
i can't believe they've aired it okay
so with the tell too like you just this
will make me feel good depending on how
you answer this question just like i
said you know oh i found when i found
out that roger ailes hated nor mcdonald
i sort of felt like okay i had some
solace i would feel are you still have
you ever been invited on bill maher's
show
oh god no okay good so then it's okay
i was thinking i was like bill maher
would want to stay as far away from you
as possible and i know now he's sort of
acknowledging that i'm not big enough to
he he didn't have you on
no no i didn't make it through a
screener no but they tried to get you
no i reached out and she asked me she
said it was this booker and she said uh
so you know what do you like want to
talk about and this is i remember at
this point oscar so white was a trend
and i said i i don't know i find it
pretty funny that oscar so white is
trending and i just watched the real
life
beauty and the beast and mary j blige is
a bookcase that turns into a queen in
1740 slavery france
and just so you want to talk about
disney movies you asked me this question
i'm like what and she goes what about
like russia trump and russia i said
what about it and oh god she's picking
on the wrongdoing right it was like
i'll call you back and then you see some
people on there i'm going that seems
like a patsy for the higher ups and i
thought
nick depalo should be on this show in
other words if he wants to have clever
people
with voices of dissent on that show you
should fit that bill
perfectly unless he doesn't want a tank
doesn't want to tangle see
that's what my buddies always said i and
i just i didn't even think it was that
sinister like i
i'm just not a big enough name i always
thought oh for christmas
he has on there absolutely yeah but
they're usually they usually like a
shitty uh conservative uh congressman
yeah like a junior senator or something
yeah yeah who just i just didn't
think and by buried i mean bill maher
has his audience of trained seals and he
just goes like
well uh that's something that can happen
in a stall with larry craig
yeah and then he brings people everybody
and then everyone
claps and he's like this is his signal
it's like this you know there's an
applause sign
it happens and now he's trying to put
that genie back in the bottle that's a
perfect evolution right now he's going
like we've made progress
and people jump all over them yeah i'm
going but bill you just
you called republicans nazis yeah i i
exactly i've been saying with all these
people that are coming around now
now that the machine they created is
coming after yeah it's like
you had a hand in this yeah you're a
huge hand your show's been on for how
many years on hbo right and getting good
numbers
you had a huge hand in where we are
today
so don't try to [ __ ] backpedal and i
hope they eat you too
right and then they say like well it
doesn't matter as long as you're funny
i'm like no look you may just agree no
one
on the planet can argue for example that
you
or nick depaul is not funny period i
always just say like there are certain
there are certain people who are just
beyond even questioning like there's
there's there are guardrails we've
talked to us with comedy there's
the bulk of it is subjective but you
have objectively funny like we mentioned
the greats like prior and
maybe you don't like personally private
yeah you might not like it but you have
to acknowledge
and objectively unfunny someone who's
been an open mic for 10 years gets
nowhere and then there's a lot of
subjective in between
you are in that objectively i don't know
a single comic who says anything other
than nick apollo is
funny well i and it tells me that i'm
like funny's not enough because for a
long time
you know i mean yeah you got punched in
the face by bitching burkins
yeah no i know it was a sucker punch you
were on our show with a black eye the
next day i think or it was the next
one i remember that happened yeah it was
right after you were on
uh when i was an ant show you were
actually promoting that gig
and i got in trouble there was a liberal
write-up cause you said some some i
think you said like some [ __ ] broad
and birkenstocks and they wrote up like
having sexist guests nick the poem like
he got
suckered no didn't even the dad you're a
man
but his uh um and i appreciate you
saying that
i always bring this up as an example
when you know
john stewart on his last episode of the
daily show
meant he said it at the very end some of
his last words because i'm looking
forward to getting back into the comedy
clubs
with colin quinn nick depaul i almost
fainted yeah somebody told me did he
ever do that though did he ever go back
to the comedy clubs yeah i saw him with
the seller here and there
okay he wouldn't shake somebody's hand
in geneva
but i took that as a you know a a big
compliment because
i like john i he's he's always been nice
to me i think he represents his side
well i hate
we would do his politics to ever do it
from there yes i agree but we were
discussing this yesterday because we
were showing him on colbert
and he buries colbert because he's not
on the extreme liberal side of
government
the most somebody wrote a great article
about that yeah the most kyle smith at
the new york post
oh yeah about how that that just showed
how
um colbert has taken you know swallowed
this kool-aid of this and it's
it's damaged his hard drive as far as
being funny absolutely you know
john was just doing what comics do look
you've been around before
pre-internet you're like i was just
talking about myspace and now you have
this successful uh
podcast and i'm really glad that your
audience has found i think you're one of
those people where the audience
needs to find you because yes just
because it's like look
you're gonna go into now as a marketing
major well i mean you're gonna go to any
comedy club in the country and you know
you're gonna you're gonna clear half of
them out if they don't know who you are
and because you've never been apologetic
which i've always really admired about
you and now people have found you
and so and you know why thanks to tommy
my manager
really because he when he started
working about three years ago he goes
he goes the comedy world knows you
people that work at comedy center you
appear
nobody knows who you are nick you know
and he
he he backs everything up he'd show me
numbers from youtube and
and that hurts and uh no but i i i sort
of knew
it doesn't hurt as much as nobody's one
night in new jersey in front of
he likes you he's 38 [ __ ] people
here's a pie chart as to why you suck
there's a pie
chart here's kevin hart no
you might as well jump off him and
commit suicide because you're done
yeah there's also 200 one-nighters in
north dakota so she could be worse yes
yeah no exactly so that's that [ __ ] but
he but but tommy knows how to market
he's a business guy
and real real smart and and a couple
months later he shows up with his
computer drives from albany down to my
house in westchester
opens that he's got a a spreadsheet of
all the counties
in in in uh the tri-state area that
voted for
said what the hell voted for that's
weird backwards l gerrymandering what
the hell's the difference
that's and he's got it all laid out a
tour for me with the counties
wow um no this guy is sharp is attacked
my manager is yeah he he has to look
into his conservative areas which is
crazy because
i was never a political comic i never
considered you a political me either
i wasn't or pushed into it yeah and i
always did just because
i could spot you from a mile away going
like oh that guy's a conservative even
though you weren't because no you're not
really
you want to hear the perfect line for
that colin quinn i go why am i keep
being called a conservative you know
he goes well you're not a concert you're
a comic who happens to lean right he
goes let's put it this way
if you're telling a joke of mcdonald's
people can tell how you voted
right that's the best way to put it yeah
tell a mcdonald's joke people can tell
how you voted yeah i mean
that that was so smartly put i say that
all the time when i'm interviewed
because i'm not i don't want to be
polite
i used to look at guys and going he used
to be funny
and now he's just all political i didn't
want to become that but this is bigger
than that
we're talking about like a societal
shift when he wasn't making
his fun you know as much fun of trump on
south park he was like well
conservatives and you know it's the new
punk rock yeah it really is because it's
going against the culture i saw him in
austin
i loved it my brother went to ut and it
was part of the rtf program where they
would come and give talks
it was matt stone actually okay and uh i
remember he was up there saying or he
was talking about the muhammad episode
of like imagination land in south park
and he said you know the thing is the
truth is we were never really at war
with christians he said they just wanted
us on later he said we wanted to be on
later
he said because we don't think kids
should be watching our shows and i
remember asking
him a question about like hey how has it
been now though that
people have been trying to go out this
is before cancel culture was a term this
might have been two thousand
five two thousand six yeah i said that
now you know you're sort of target
number one from the left
and he just sort of started explaining
it and very rationally kind of going off
on them and saying well we
didn't really have a problem with
christians and so what happened was we
tried to put muhammad in an episode
and comedy central said you can't and we
said okay but it's going to be one of
the
whatever 14 episodes you pay for this
season and then we made it a
three-parter
and you just and ever you could hear pin
drop because the kids there were
and i remember thinking oh this is weird
i thought college they're gonna see
matt stone they would be on board and
they were uncomfortable
yeah he's more our generation when you
think about it too yeah but that was for
me when i saw oh there's a shift going
on
yeah i can see that fully early on um
but with you but you were you were i
always like
it happened with me and john's uh john
stossel i remember as a kid i used to
watch you know tgif
and then john you tell me this story i i
don't know downstairs
i don't know what john stossel yeah i
don't remember i don't know
how much of the whiskey did you have
depends are you remembering something
that's not
i never tell anybody else okay that
means he's had a good amount if he
starts doing the godfather i'm good
no i thought go ahead i just remember
and i just did an interview with john
stossel where it broke my like people
know it broke my heart because recent
right
recently where he was like you know i
think some of your material is
mean you shouldn't be making fun
you talk to everyone of their children
yeah but i was a kid it was tgif
and i didn't know what a conservative
was and i told john stotzel's story and
it kind of turned the interview a little
bit because i told him
when people ask me my show i say picture
letterman meets john stossel which meets
howard stern that's the closest thing i
would compare it to
uh because those were probably my
biggest influences i read his biography
i read his books
i knew all about a stutter problem when
he grew up i know which producers hated
him at abc
and there's a little gallagher in there
too but go ahead
and uh the older brother and he goes uh
he's be
he's interviewing and i said i like i
said i don't know what that guy is but i
wanna i want more of that he was
interviewing a guy on a native american
reservation
and i laughed so hard i couldn't breathe
he was interviewing him and this
guy's talking about you know the white
man and all the stuff and how they
fought and he goes
right but you live in a modern house
with
running water and television and
electricity
he goes well that's because the white
man forces me to to live this way and
john stops the camera you know comes
back and goes
but you're wearing jeans
and then the camera kind of pulls out
and this is native american with his
ponytail and he's wearing old like lois
dungarees and i said what is this and
it's just it was again it was sort of
this natural anti-authority
authority yeah it says foursquare i
think i saw you did you do the nasty
show at the just for laughs oh god
many times then that must have been
where i saw you they handed it to me
after bobby slayton which was a huge i'm
like i think i did it
two years in a row after bobby and i'm
like this is my permanent gig
were you hosting it then i didn't hear
from you but you did a gap you did a
gala too
you did dallas i did gala's too yeah i
saw you as a so i was watching you
because i was a seat filler my mom was
oh yeah you tell me my mom was a costume
designer i saw the set that
got ray romano everybody loves raymond
at the just for last and kevin james and
i remember uh
and i remember seeing seeing you and so
it's just i was just absorbing all of
this yeah
as a kid and there were people who i
right away said oh i like that
and it was great the first i did that
nasty show
ten times probably the first five or six
were great
i mean that place sells out every year
would be the first
gala to sell out the nasty shows okay i
think it was a club soda was it yeah
yeah well it um there was two yeah the
first one was the old club soda
right and then they opened this bigger
venue and and uh that held even more
and they were so fun people knew what it
said right on the thing you know nasty
show
people knew what they were getting boy
they would work you though we would do
two shows a night like from month to
tuesday to
thursday and then on the weekends three
friday three sets i mean yeah and then
three two sunday
just packs packed all of them yeah but
then you know after like the fifth the
sixth one they started to moan a little
bit
and i noticed even up there turning
you know and by the last one i did i was
like this is
i was scolding the audience half the
time oh yeah i can i can imagine it's so
strange because you
they buy tickets for a nasty show and i
would show up
wanting to see exactly that because
their definition dave of nasty as this
you know
a civilian is different than ours well
there's a right
here's the thing though yeah we we
always will say something whatever
christmas whatever you're like oh right
that wasn't for you guys that's right
something for real in your head you're
trying to make louie laugh
meanwhile
like that was the real god pushing this
thing off me yeah anyway
yeah i'm in a room of god's chosen
people but he's mad at you
um so but i i remember yeah they they
the thing is you can be as dirty as you
and you're not necessarily an overall
dirty community but the thing is for
example amy schumer can talk about how
her you know
smells like a barn animal no one cares
but the second you get
edgy meaning what is predetermined to be
offensive right
and that's what's so crazy for example i
was always whenever i did it was
clean but i was being banned from
colleges in 2005.
i remember they said oh you did a joke
about muhammad you can't do that yeah
and then and then i have nick apollo
calling me up one time where his
his thumbnail picture was next to a
picture around that he called me are you
out of your [ __ ] mind
so
[Applause]
i'm in watertown new york i'm sleeping
above the theater
bin laden's got a satellite roman uh it
is probably
good that they shut down the comedy club
in dearborn that's a good uh
they don't necessarily have a swat team
at italian villa east in lancaster
pennsylvania
could you review that place go to
italian villa east no
i've been left there calm to find out
where you can kill me
that's exactly right here's a layout
here's the website of the club
well that's what's you know you say that
but i got a couple death threats uh
last year and it was creepy because i'm
[ __ ]
going to vegas oh the guy said i'm going
to be out there
you know so we had to i was on the phone
with the [ __ ] fbi twice
wow and going to vegas you're safe they
only shoot white country concerts
yeah well anyways you know the guy said
he's going to be i'm going to your
second job but
and you know we we had to make aware of
the security at the hotel all the [ __ ]
yeah now you come out when you're in to
do you don't think that was on my mind
the lights
you know you get introduced yeah it's
all [ __ ] dark i'm waiting no oh yeah
am i gonna just make it quick not in the
face
i had i i was at um brett garrett it's
like two months ago and i said something
where a muslim guy walked out
and uh brad's nephew runs the place and
he's standing there and he goes
well that guy's he's saying you know you
shouldn't wear masks he's like no he
said he doesn't like to wear a mask and
he goes
well he says muslims have no sense of
humor and he goes well you are leaving
aren't you for example okay let me ask
you let me ask you this
all these little cocktails there's still
a list of his hobbies yeah some guy
shows up i hear you like prostate exams
that's finger puppet
that's a call back we'll call it here at
isis
um lead with your b material close with
your a
i i yeah i uh i i i actually
i mean i haven't done a live last live
show we did was at uh u of m
before the pandemic but unless we have
full security i started getting for the
first time like actual because
i actually had you know i'm actually on
the isis kill list and uh like
everyone's on this is gonna talk me no
no everyone's on the ice will kill this
but i'm like on the frequent flyer list
you just talked to them they posted
they posted my home address so maybe you
understand why i get a little nervous
huh right yes i understand
now you get it but they posted my home
address my wife's work attractions
my wife's work address and the local
police show up to my house and the pa
the the path from my wife's work to my
house this is i don't know
when i lived in michigan and the local
police show up because a fan from london
this was in a comment
under a youtube video the local police
show up because a fan from london
saw the address posted by the terrorist
cross-referenced the zip code and called
the local police
and and then it got worse and worse from
there and um i just would start getting
these like horrible anxiety before going
on stage because people don't know when
you're on stage you can't really see the
audience right you're just totally
exposed
and it always bothered me because i felt
like it was something no just ask
dimebag daryl
i was like with something stolen from me
but it does change you know amy schumer
never has to worry about that
kevin hart probably know the rest they
might have to worry about you know
someone living in their basement like
letterman but if you watch
the [ __ ] listen to the left-wing
narrative or whatever you'd think that's
the only people that would have to worry
about it
oh yeah is amy schumer yeah because
someone's in heart because we live in
such a white supremacist society oh of
course
sexist misogynistic couldn't be further
from the truth and i'm so sick of
i've been [ __ ] saying this me and
colin for a thousand years you know
you see these left-wing comics talk
about race you know
but they'll sean white people and people
after the show that guy was edgy he was
talking about race
yeah no no no no no being edgy's being
at the comedy cellar doing a dominican
joke in front of a table of dominicans
who that's being even kennison said that
years ago
how can you tell that that's what i i
like you can't you have to ask them
then you go into the materials i like
already dominic and they go no columbia
they go what's that a
eighth of a gram difference yeah you say
this one's for you i had a cocaine
casey yeah the thing is it really is
surprising to me i guess that that so
many comedians have tossed their lot in
with it and it's sort of pulling the
ladder up behind them that's what uh
because i don't i purples you don't i i
just put my thing on i
i don't watch other karma i nev even
when i was on comedy central i'd watch
the tough crowd episode
right i wouldn't watch uh other guys
specials or i just wanted to
do what i was doing and be and and
that's not the smartest uh
you know way to go buddy you should stay
a little bit and
watch the young guys coming up and sh
but since they're all cookie card
most of them yeah uh i've just i've
tuned them out for the last few
years i don't you know i mean don't do
this the wrong way but there's no 30
year old nick apollo
and there will never be another 20 year
old nick apollo it won't happen it can't
happen
and there should be at least one you
don't think uh
no and it's sad to me what's the italian
lesbian's name i thought she was a lot
like
[Laughter]
[Applause]
there's only one bad impression he did
it's just you and it's a reader it's me
doing
jokes it's a reboot of tootsie nick
uh all right well look we're gonna go to
mud club uh this is a lot of fun all
right listen uh it's over no no it's not
over it's the comics gym you got nothing
to do
it's nice and you by the way you can you
can use your vape you had your cigar you
can have your vape now
it's the comics gym.com right the comics
gym.com absolutely
five o'clock eastern is when you're just
when we when we drop the show
yeah and i highly recommend monday
through thursday it's very worthwhile
and nick was one of the first guys to
really really do
i guess i would say one of the guests
who i was nervous about approaching
and would appear on the show early on
when we did not have anywhere near
as many of you guys watching so i i
really do appreciate it and do support
his live shows
i have there are very few people who
make me
double over laughing as much as nick
depaolo the comics jim
i have that right dot com we're going to
mug club youtube thank you piss off
hey everybody if you liked the clip you
just saw go ahead and smash that like
button
smash it also feel free to go ahead and
share it why not
share it give people you like or you
don't like landow smash
landau smash crowder smash black widow
thanks for smashing